good evening and welcome to a special
inside the issues edition of tucker
carlson tonight we're taking a deeper
dive for the next hour beneath the
headlines in to some of the issues that
influence the way America is changing
first tonight when Robert Muller's final
report on Russia came out this spring
the geniuses on television had one word
for it
damming truly and completely damning so
damning you could block the Colorado
River with it and create your own
hydropower it was that damming watch the
report contains a potentially damning
list of ways the president tried to
quote influence the investigation
arguing that the Muller report is far
more damning and it's not pretty it is
an ugly damning piece of business I
agree with him that it's absolutely
damning Democrats say the report is
damning report from the special counsel
is more damning than all those reports
far more damning to the president than
the Attorney General initially indicated
but it's still very damning as we told
you damning and that's the geniuses
concluded before a single one of them
had even read the report in fact they
still haven't read it but eventually
other people did read it or skim it and
those people let our trusted television
journalists know that actually Mulder's
report really didn't say very much there
was no collusion in it much less treason
there was much of anything actually
it was disappointing so at that point
the media and their masters in the
Democratic Party had a choice to make
they could have moved on and started
worrying about America's actual problems
there are many of those war they could
double down in a week hand and demand
that Robert Muller come testify before
Congress as you know they chose the
latter Muller himself did not want to
participate in any of this he didn't see
the point of it but Democrats insisted
and so this Wednesday Muller shuffled up
to Capitol Hill Democrats prodded him
like a zoo animal hoping that he would
transform suddenly into Clarence Darrow
and deliver an epic speech denouncing
Trump as a traitor to our nation in a
war criminal but he didn't do that so
california's ted Lieu pushed
who tried to make Muller explain that
even though he did not indict Donald
Trump Trump should still be in prison
and I'd like to ask you the reason again
that you did not indict Donald Trump is
because of OLC opinion stating that you
cannot a date a sitting president
correct that is correct
Oh get it
orange Mussolini was a criminal all
along Muller never said Trump committed
a crime in his report he also didn't say
that his press conference or in his
opening statement but finally Ted Lou
was able to extract the truth from
Robert Muller president Trump is a
criminal except not a few hours later
Muller backtracked and clarified that he
had not called the president a criminal
watch now before we go to questions I
want to add one correction to my
testimony this morning I want to go back
to one thing that was said this morning
by mr. Lew who said and I quote you
didn't charge the president because of
the OLC opinion that is not the correct
way to say it as we say in the report
and as I said at the opening we did not
reach a determination as to whether the
president committed a crime as we say in
the report and as I said at the opening
in other words Muller wasn't saying
anything new he was just repeating what
he'd been saying for months the
congressman ted Lieu was not convinced
by this indeed ted Lieu smelled a rat
there had to be a reason that Robert
Muller was unwilling to disavow two
years of work in all of his prior
statements to produce a democratic
talking point for ted Lieu what could
the reason be ted Lieu had a pretty good
idea clearly the Russians had gotten to
Muller - you were at the center
yesterday of one of the most dramatic
moments of the hearings with robert
muller you have to walk back his
testimony to you in response to your
questioning wasn't until there was a
recess and the Intel committee that he
started to walk some of that back I
don't know who got to him I don't know
who talked to them but that was very odd
what he did well what are you suggesting
are you saying he only did that because
of pressure from someone
I don't know but he clearly answered the
way he answered to me and then he had
numerous times to walk that back so I
don't really understand what happened
hmm
now to be clear this is a diagnosis this
is how crazy people talk tinfoil Ted is
a nut cake he's like your cousin who's
convinced the moon landing was faked on
a soundstage Ted Lou thinks he's got
secret knowledge that explains
everything
how the Russians get to Robert Muller
wasn't at cash bribe in rubles could
have been brainwashing are they holding
some of his kids hostage at Lubyanka
prison hopefully one of our dutiful
congressional correspondence will ask
Ted Lou for details we'd like to know
but first it might be worth checking in
with Lou's colleague Eric SWA well if
you think Ted Lou has gone around the
bend and he has you haven't listened to
SWA well recently he sets the standard
listen to Eric's wall will explain that
Vladimir Putin is somehow controlling
our voting machines watch this I fear
that we are more vulnerable than we were
in 2016 because Russia and other
countries will see the United States is
open for business when it comes to
interference well do you worry that the
Russians have developed the capability
to actually change vote vote counts in
the United States yes yes and to think
there are people who believe we should
legalize hallucinogenic mushrooms a mind
is a terrible thing to waste it's status
held to watch actually but it's also
unnerving because adult political
parties must exist in tangible reality
democratic party no longer does 40 years
have accused anyone who's ever read a
Tolstoy novel of being a Russian agent
and they mean it Stacey Abrams doubts
that she's the real governor of Georgia
after losing by 50,000 votes
Gendry Acacio Cortez told us recently
that border enforcement is actually a
plot to build Nazi death camps in
America and so on these are not minor
figures in the Democratic Party these
are its leaders what's gonna happen when
these people get to run the country